you tattooed your cast members is this
right yeah we call them tomojis and you
do them all the cast no weirdly enough
no one else wanted them um other people
just would come by the trailer and get
anything and yeah so I did all sorts of
things I reckon I've done probably like
getting close to 100 now we have a
tattoo gun here oh boy so if any of your
graduates want a tattoo oh do you to
commemorate this lovely evening
you kissed her here
you pierced your ear uh yeah not myself
um
funny please
I'm seeing you actually are prepared oh
yeah
this isn't actually my gun but I could I
can make do with it for sure
when you're thinking about this no
you were because you were not at all
that's acting
okay